mais la maîtrise m messieurs bonsoir
bienvenue à champigny où vous allez voir
suivre un grand combat de catch à 4 en
compagnie de notre invité d'honneur ici
à ma droite bernard menez bonsoir passé
mais qu'est ce qui vous est arrivé et
ben comme on prend le match en plein
cours là je viens de le faire mal il ya
un catcheur qui est venu s'entraîner sur
moi il m'a donné un grand coup au bout
d'une loi et heureusement les
secouristes sont venus à mon secours aaa
et m'ont fait joli pouvait bien sûr je
les poupées à à bordeaux alors ce n'est
qu'au repas
[Musique]
de combat va opposer le marquis richard
fumoleau de la rossignolette ici à
gauche de l'écran
accompagné de son fidèle majordome paul
butin pluchard le marquis va être
associé à black shadow et cette équipe
voilà qui s'inscrit sur votre écran
voyez marie richard du polo de la
rossignolette loyer et nourrir lac tchad
où on peut pas le louper
opposé à marcelo motta et angelito
angelito voyez sur la droite
complètement à droite de l'écran c'est
marcelo motta et puis celui qui a un
petit peu moins de cheveux que marcelo
motta et qui est en combinaison blanche
avec de jolies vagues bleues si la csg
litho que l'on appelle le petit prince
de la baule fille alors c'est un combat
est un combat de voltigeur parce que
vous savez bernard que angelito est
surnommé le petit prince de la voltige
et des détritus et il est très impatient
la de plaisir 6 avant que ça commence
etc
il est très fraîche où il en veut il
ajoutant berges impression dans la
bouche
c'est au rize et ça oui oui oui oui oui
oui si on s'en tient pas pour l'étirer
étranglé son adversaire après ses bons
alors angelito se trouve opposé la à
black shadow
la mèche
à la blague shadow keita qui est un
champion de champion du maroc d'ailleurs
blacksad on a eu déjà l'occasion je
crois devoir lutter sur antenne 2 a beau
champion du maroc
oui oui ça commence vite alors tu sais
pas si vous avez remarqué là à notre
gauche je dis là pour eux aujourd'hui
l'âge à gauche à
y'a des siens à personnages les agrégés
de pardon excusez moi mais c'est
étonnant
c'est une sorte de grand chien qui est
assis et senza caméra bon parleur guen
il avait une bague il avait gardé
motards ivoire regardez regardez le
regarder il appelle albéric voilà et y
est étonnant
albéric grand un passionné de cash
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pendant ce temps là il y avait marqué
qu'à essayer de garder sa bague et la
bombe
on lui avait retiré ah bah oui hélas pas
loin de garder à garder sa chevalière
avec ses armoiries 1
[Applaudissements]
bien entendu ces deux manches et une
belle s'il ya lieu limitée a donc l'idée
de marquer face à marcelo motta est un
garçon de 85 kg fait passer à plat de la
porte dans les grands moments
[Applaudissements]
il serait un peu faux sont martin ça
m'étonnerait pas oui et il n'aime pas
beaucoup le contact direct avec ces
manants à ahola je suis parti sur son
séant après un coude afin et et
renverser encore dans une position bien
inconfortable pour marquer par chenoua
des supporters c cnet
mais vous savez qu'il est il est
d'origine portugaise et c'est un petit
peu le régional de l'étape car idée de
champigny ah ouais il est visiblement il
s'agit de popularité oui mais voilà pour
la blague chanot
ou la première de hanche en black shadow
lia à regina et les survoltés a fait de
loin à la volée la veille alger les gens
qui s'agitent là dans les cars lila
relais et après on se place bien sûr
leur égard
alors angelito face à blake jallo at on
s'agite là j'ai apprécié que texas aux
25 mètres le public ado blatche halals
oui oui avec shadow à la haye où là la
haye pédales en haut mais à l'époque on
est là on va se termine par un coup
d'arrêt à ces artistes
ouais c'était un coup de boule amicale
pour la poule à
qu'est-ce que j'en fais je l'envoie sur
la table des officiels
[Applaudissements]
et l'attrait de monsieur le marquis
voyait avec pas le butin fischer ont
fait des lettres est fait reste il est
hué casse les cordes pour que le marché
n'est pas toi se plier pour
c'est pas un pari gratuit et garçons à
bastia ils ne regardent pas dans les
yeux
[Musique]
richard lui vole haut de la rue lionel
marty de son état angeli tout à graz en
catcheur également qu'ils n'hésitent pas
à se frotter
à des hommes comme angelito
la bêta
photo mike aux interventions la cavaille
le mari a emmené en dit peu dans son
coin là pour que pleut le vilain
majordome puis tu sers également sont
nommés
me paraît pas très nettes ce majeur de
ben un style et oui il faut bien qu'ils
justifient ces gages un point
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aurillac
oui voilà oui bah oui ma à sénat bascule
à huy hà au plat
bon
ice en deux
[Applaudissements]
l'arbitrage qu'il a compté jusqu'à trois
là bas je crois que pas vraiment est-ce
qu'il a eu le temps de compter jusqu'à
toi ben non alors
[Musique]
j'ai vu j'ai vu black shadow et puis
demain jordan s'est précipité sur
angelito et du coup j'ai pas vu leur vie
contre les minarets n'a pas compté c'est
la boxe ça a changé
oui alors en piste black shadow et
marcelo motta
[Applaudissements]
allez on sait ça fait mal ça coule à la
à ouïr tordre le bras comme ça ça fait
très mal
bah
et revoilà et voiliers albéric
l'activation occuper un peu il va signer
palais mordiller gentiment les mots les
images de la nasa de l'autre souffre
comme une bête traquée
[Applaudissements]
moi je trouve que je compte le maroquin
francky les bagnes échange ale laver les
cheveux là j'ai appris les cheveux c'est
vrai que pour tirer des changes il te
reconnais alors c'est vrai et pose et
des shows de joie de albéric le grand
châle
[Musique]
alors
mais je marque hypothèse
[Applaudissements]
la digue est cassé en deux mais c'est
marc qui passe à marcelo motta ans les
cheveux roux les cheveux alors la
traîtrise l'intervention du jld un vrai
look l'arbitré ne le voit pas tout
intervention du majordome et wii et wii
[Applaudissements]
messieurs
allah
les marques et vous occupe du bras droit
de marcel mauss la vie ça paye un verger
à regarder avec envie fayote alors le
fayot le fayot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui c'est à dire les bonnes grâces de
larbitre en les plongeant comme ça chez
l'abbé belle bodegas bandas en
planchette japonaise de marcelo motta et
relais angeli d'or face donc remarquer
[Musique]
double n'aime ça
ah bien sûr passé at il fait une pompe
[Musique]
ah ah ah ah il est lourd à soulever ce
marqué ya hélas de l'a6 il a la cote
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
surpris car un paquet de la salle
[Applaudissements]
à l'extérieur le marquis comprenez voilà
à voile à me servir ils encaissent pas
bien je trouve
bah oui au parquet où la 125 comme et
les deux bouts live au mais nous a fait
deux chutes arrière d'al ou pas si vous
pouvez m'en drainage abadie nas baala
est la muse un exemple monsieur le
banquier a légué
[Applaudissements]
mais les deux shows qu'il a fait les
vols planés du marc ayrault des
impressionnants là
[Applaudissements]
si on avait fait pas sûr d'avoir anttila
sur ce coup bas à la répartie récupère à
bülach alors regardez ces chutes arrière
formidable voilà une
elle se leva et vale a envoyé le
deuxième pas regarder sa pop et a les
mains sales trop pourquoi ni comment ils
tombent
il se relève ah qu'est-ce que j'en fais
là ah oui oui là il va donner un coup de
genou dans le dos et marcheurs non
monsieur marc et ils viennent d'arriver
bien des malheurs de cette séquence dans
son bail à la voilà les impressionnants
c'est le cerveau n'est fait pour
impressionner l'adversaire c'est vrai je
dois tu passais sait jamais où ils vont
aller là puisse un jour lui a ils sont
un peu décontenancé en façade avoir deux
garçons qui voltigent de cette manière
angelito et black shadow
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
richard oland ont les oreilles cool coup
de talon dans les oreilles voilà année
dans les cordes alors va se lâcher la
voilà ouais à et pasz l'oralair débiteur
alors marcelo très encouragé marcel
[Musique]
aïe aïe aïe là il est parvenu sur aulas
là où ça fait pas de sens aïe aïe aïe
et c'est chuté aussi elle en profite
le [ __ ] n'a rien entendu a valu des
vies si elle arrive à uddevalla voulant
pas oh ça fait mal ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
disons que c'est un massage facial assez
particulier un coin alors le marquis
maintenant face à un moteur ça secoue un
gîte rural et oui la du var a du mal à
dormir ce soir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah très impressionnant
ah il a l'air déterminé qu il ait pris
la 6 e à la gare aux altérations garder
matin
monsieur larvée depuis ce temps d'aller
voir ce qui se passe là-bas alors c'est
fini là on se calme bon
black shadow man à face à marcelo mahdia
les relais ça change tout et voit les
objets du sentier de la guerre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est 4h02 black shadow un cabas ya des
moments ils se baladent il est très sûr
de lui une sévère et très bon très
désagréable quand même
[Applaudissements]
là
encore un coup des repas pour l'envoyer
volée alors doucement
[Applaudissements]
averses voire angelito je sais pas du
tout comparé à janvier de bonne
composition joliton prends ça avec un
calme et une sérénité à toute épreuve
[Applaudissements]
voilà il va être penser à la fin du mois
là
toi lui d'un pluchard c'est qu'il est
suisse
ah bah oui mais oui c'est vrai donc les
suisses avaient donc il doit être bien
payé là bas il est de lausanne est là
l'accent est faux de pardon la manger
toute demande pardon pour tout ce qu'il
a fait avant et oui ça dure face au
plein boom
les gars et il est bien vrai sheila le
majordome là bas il est intervenu ça
ap
association
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant ces femmes
[Applaudissements]
belga voilà quand votre serviette pour
monsieur le marquis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
angeli to black shadow je sais pas où il
est passé et fait ça on se lâche la
voilà on se lâche parce que tout le
monde dans les cordes
c'est bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
machel marqué sur le sur le ring là
[Musique]
n'est pas resté mon père de moulins
à
[Rires]
non en plat
ah ça y est un oui et là ils n'ont pas
eu le temps d'intervenir là
sauf qu'on relevait le malheureux
marquée revient rage
[Applaudissements]
première manche angelito marcelo motta
peuvent rien fait du côté d'al d'eric la
ronde entre ayant maille fait des bonds
chabot a chopé joie
[Applaudissements]
il saute pas de jaloux
voilà caméral mairie
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà alors maintenant on souffle
pendant une petite minute et
en éponge monsieur le marquis il va même
lui donner leurs coiffes et la gare il
est réalisable
alia et l'arrco mais le marquis n'a pas
beaucoup de cheveux
donc il n'y a pas besoin d'avoir
beaucoup de dents au peigne à wii fit
d'ailleurs soigner les arbitres en même
temps oui on sait jamais ça peut servir
[Applaudissements]
et bien ça c'est un petit peu la
serviette tout à l'heure pour l'éponger
à laver le voyait alors le marque me
regarder car il est bien coiffé vonn par
monsieur marc servait servier la sas et
ryan
comment ça va votre doigt la pourpre ou
championnat je souffre pour eux abordent
[Musique]
alors encore une intervention là
[Applaudissements]
un spectateur qui était tombé à terre
par damart de voix nous allons
intervenir ouais alors c'est terminé
[Applaudissements]
alors on l'a raccompagnée à se rasseoir
la bam que c'est pas plus mal
oulala on dans votre coffre ap la haye
ou au coût deux fois encore la d
coût de poids encore du majordome
alors dans la solution saas explique
hiroshi le rabbin pas sauvé la vie sans
expliquer que l'autre adumin à il se
passe quelque chose dans la salle est
pas alors on se calme et on s'assied
maintenant et on regarde ce que font ces
jeunes gens
pour l'instant c'est une clé au bras
pensé par le marquis angelito
[Musique]
alors ça va j'ai dit on en prend plein
les allées oui avant le marocain profite
la salle
oula à lui écrase la tête carrément
rayak gens rien que ça oui je la termine
là à trois feuilles a4 dans les majeures
d'améliorer sur le coup d'arrêt étaient
tous
allah
[Musique]
sa patte arrière comme ça aulas
marshall en rien à ce qui se passe
l'ess proférées par l'arbitré vous plaît
monsieur larry à
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
aïe l'épave est ce majordome à la junte
à dire la tête comme ça obama et tous
les droits ont permis vous savez au
catch quels sont les coûts qui ne sont
pas permis
faut vraiment avoir la tête sur un roc
ah bah oui bah c'est le cas royal
pourtant c'est un pin's et à rock bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors j'ai dit oh là là regardez les
toits alors qu'ils comptaient alors quoi
1 2 non c'est trop tard on est venu
compter trop tard la foule est restée
longtemps immobilisé angelito il a été
occupé à autre chose là bas
oui cible c'était un peu justice qui
n'est pas content et il était alors
regardez moi ça va en faire
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire ouhlala oui
lui a brisé les reins est là c'était sur
le célé comme flottante la moyenne sur
le sur le vendredi par un méchant coup
aucune pitié
vous avez vu comment il le tenait à bout
de bras la d'après challans partir quand
j'ai dit oh il
et les 75 kg quand même la tête en
pointe
[Musique]
avertissements à la avertissement aux
autres trios la de blagues château du
marquis et du vagin
ces personnes les arrête pas vraiment
non non on va dire aïe aïe ohlala même
la main entre les jambes je sais pas si
vous voyez ce que je veux dire
ça fait ça peut faire très mal ces
choses là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors pour l'instant à l'oreille et
point goût et termina pas de cheveux non
l'apa par les oreilles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va oulalala bien des passions
renault a permis de la conduire vers le
port de casques doivent être
obligatoires up réception par le
majordome de alors et il tient toujours
le détour et quand même assistant il a
quand même des ressources à un tête dure
souvent oui ok quand on regarde en gros
plan on voit qu'elle est un peu cabossée
1,7 jean prat didace pour vous faire un
gros plan rapport à ça c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
hahaha
et j'ai pris 10 sur 26 mère ressent ça
et voilà au brésil
et les premiers 3 eva dalak shadow alors
halak shadow redis je sais pas c'est ma
jardin par semaine et baskets
ah ouais c'est la leçon là alors
halpérin
[Musique]
sur le fleuve à jordan a cherché un
abbaoui à lennon alors qu'est ce qui
nous fait là marcelo
alors le marquis a passé le relais à
black shadow mais il ya un
un moment de règlements de compte le
choix adore aller j'appuie la dgal une
personne dégagé et un gîte au vol ou
continuer deux noms éloquent regardez la
halle au ralenti à bordj et l'histoire
et qu'il a fait il a éjecté là alors il
a manqué à la haye leur venue les
caméras plus d'âme ans changent de côté
tué parce qu'il faut quand même pas
recevoir un k à ka jazz 1
[Applaudissements]
mais là il est revenu alors qu'audard
par l eau la la la
[Applaudissements]
allez ola
non
à 2-2 se terminer
samedi soir les nations et continue à le
faire à condition
voilà encore pas terminée voilà avec toi
de là et à chelito il va dire encore
quelques petits mois
un vrai cadeau alors victoire par deux
manches à zéro 2 algérie tôt et barnes
et le motard un triomphe à riom pour le
couple passe d'autres cas au marquis
richard plus beaux lots de laroche idole
est associé
à black shadow est bien entendu au
majordome paul butin pigeard venu tout
droit de suite
bouchard bernard il va maintenant de
nous quitter
j'arrive de votre doigt ira mieux oui je
crois que c'est pas grave qu'est ce qui
s'est passé là dessus de ses moyens oui
eh bien nous en sommes tout à fait ravis
de cette bonne soirée passée on a
vraiment passé une très bonne soirée à
et je dois dire que j'ai des commandes
jaillir des champions de haut vol
il n'arrête pas oui moi je ne serai pas
bons doigts en jeu devant les
énergumènes pareil c'est sympathique de
voir que les c'est quand même les autres
ont tellement été méchant par moments
trois d'entre eux des instances il est
la victime est allée le public et le
portent en triomphe voilà l hôpital bois
bon eh bien merci bernard d'avoir tout
fait pour échapper au 12e c'était donc
un reportage de
jean paris nice pour les images avec les
moyens techniques de fr3 disons merci et
bonne fin de soirée à bientôt verna
alphonse est
[Musique]